verblüffen der planet merkur schrumpft
was es mit dem incredible shrinking des
merkur auf sich hat jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction
es gibt überraschende neuigkeiten zum
planeten merkur auf bildern die von der
nasa raumsonde messenger gemacht wurden
konnten forscher beobachten dass der
merkur noch immer sehr aktiv ist hier
noch mal kurz ein paar fakten zu merkur
merkur das ist der kleinste planet im
gesamten sonnensystem also der auch
tatsächlich noch als planet gilt sein
durchmesser beträgt 4.000 900 kilometer
zum vergleich bei der erde sind es
12.800 der merkur hat die geringste
entfernung zur sonne und das hat einen
erheblichen nachteil dadurch dass er so
nah an der sonne also dreimal so nah an
der sonne wie unsere erde ist ist es
wegen der hohen temperaturen die
mittlere temperatur beträgt 167 grad
celsius und der intensiven
strahlenbelastung schwerin zu erkunden
auch von der erde aus ist er wegen der
sonnennähe schwer zu beobachten auch mit
raumsonden hing die forschung etwas
hinterher
bisher gab es nur zwei sonden die den
planeten angeflogen haben unter anderem
ist das gravitationsfeld der sonne so
stark dass es schwer ist sondern dort
sicher hinzuschicken damit ist der
merkur einer der am wenigsten
erforschten planeten im gesamten
sonnensystem besonders an den planeten
ist allerdings die tatsache dass es dort
wasser gibt in krater rändern an den
polkappen hat man spuren von wasser
entdeckt außerdem gehört merkur auch zu
dem planeten mit der höchsten dichte im
sonnensystem und warum das so ist sieht
man schnell wenn man den aufbau von
merkur am sind 70% des planeten bestehen
aus dem mars erreichen kern das ist bei
keinem anderen planeten der fall
ein grund dafür könnte darin liegen dass
merkur mal viel größer war und ein oder
mehrere große einschläge ein teil des
merkur einfach abgesprengt haben dass
der planet einmal größer war gilt
inzwischen als erwiesen wie forscher im
fachmagazin nature geoscience jetzt
berichteten scheint die planeten
aktivität des merkurs im gegensatz zu
rückläufigen meinung noch immer sehr
hoch zu sein zitat bilder von carne
group einem der größten steinstufen auf
der nordhalbkugel des merkurs deuten
darauf hin dass die darunterliegende
verwerfung erst kürzlich reaktiviert
wurde so die experten
auf den aufnahmen der nasa raumsonde
messenger fand man
diese verwerfung und ordnete sie
zeitlich auch direkt ein zitat das
ständige meteoriten bombardement
degradiert und zerstört strukturen
dieser größe normalerweise sehr schnell
diese falten können daher erst vor
kurzem entstanden sein
das sagte maria banks vom planetary
science institute im zuge der aktiven
plattentektonik könnte merkur nicht nur
immer kleiner werden auch seine
tektonische aktivität sei sehr hoch
es kommt also ständig zu erdbeben wie
die experten in ihrem artikel
beschreiben sei der fast nur noch aus
seinem kern bestehende planet seismisch
nicht zu unterschätzen wird der merkur
also in naher oder wohl etwas fernerer
zukunft immer kleiner und brüchiger
werden
incredible shrinking wie die nasa den
vorgang bezeichnet wird mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit noch lange andauern
der planet verschwindet also nicht von
jetzt auf gleich seine größe wird sich
aber definitiv noch weiter verändern er
wird kleiner
die genaue äußerliche entwicklung lässt
sich allerdings nicht genau
prognostizieren
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
lass mir gerne einen daumen nach oben
hoch und abonniert einfach dafür hier
klicken kostenlos klicks und wenn er
hier klickt da geht's zu einem video in
dem wir uns mit graphit ablagerungen auf
dem merkur beschäftigen was denkt ihr
über die entwicklung des planeten könnte
er irgendwann verschwunden sein weil er
zu viele einschläge abbekommen hat
schreibt mir eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran